we have with us today at the studio Paul
Collier who's the professor of economics
at the University of Oxford and also
director of the African Center for
economic studies welcome Paul thanks
Africa is actually held up as a kind of
poster child for all that is wrong with
globalization now why is it that Africa
has failed so I personally in benefiting
from globalization which has helped
countries in East Asia particularly
China and Southeast Asia and India
actually to grow so fast yeah well
Africa is a big place and it doesn't
make much sense to talk about it as just
one entity so but let's try a radical
simplification and put it into three
groups three groups defined by different
opportunities and approximately 1/3 of
Africa's population is in each group and
they go like this one third is countries
that are defined by having resource
wealth a lot of natural resources
another third is chemistry's that don't
have resource wealth but at least a
coastal and then final third is
countries that neither have resource
wealth nor a coastal now what is the
significance of coastal ok the countries
that don't have resource wealth but a
coastal had and still have to an extent
the opportunity to develop in the way
that we understand best in the rest of
the world which is basically breaking
into labor-intensive by the
manufacturers or services selling them
on global markets Africa like India and
China 20 years ago has a huge amount of
labor that has very low incomes and that
the when globalization works well it
provides the opportunity to convert that
labor
into products that use a lot of labour
and and that way people drive up their
incomes the great advantage of that
process is that because the world market
in labor intensive Goods is huge
relative to the size of coasts of Africa
if African countries could break into
these markets they could grow like Topsy
now Madagascar I suppose is the only
success story in that area right it's
just starting to be a success story and
well Mauritius is the exact right have
an African country that has dramatically
transformed itself from a dirt-poor
sugar island to an upper middle-income
country they did it pretty fast the the
tragedy is it's it's the only story as
you say Madagascar is starting to do
that it's had a lot of political
obstacles within Madagascar the export
processing zone that got established
very quickly generated 300,000 jobs
which is a lot in a population of only
15 million and then there was an
election the former president who lost
wouldn't step down he blockaded his own
port for eight months and if you're
running an export processing zone and
the port is blockaded you're dead so
this political instability yes is that a
factor in it it's one factor and more
commonly I think what happened is we go
back the big opportunity for Africa to
have broken into these markets was in
the 1980s why the 1980s because back in
the 1980s Asia wasn't already firmly
established in these markets now China's
established in manufacturing market
India in the services markets both of
them have benefited from the glomer
asians specialized agglomerations of
these activities which will lower their
costs and so it's harder game
rattle eager to play 20 years ago it
could have been a level playing field it
could have broken in and what stopped
Africa a number of things stopped it but
I think above all and coast of Africa
happened to have that variety what we
call syndromes of poor policies of
various forms economic control regimes
in some countries looting by narrow
elites in other countries that basically
precluded the rather Footloose export
activities that were driven away either
because the costs were too high or the
risks were too high and a lot of those
syndromes have gone the last decade or
so has been a period of substantial
reform in Africa but in a way it it's
missed the boat that now Asia's
established Africa isn't why things have
gone all right in Madagascar recently
sort of all right is thanks to a goer
the Africa growth and opportunity Act
their ministers of the United States
which effectively provided protection
for Africa against Asia in US markets
the European Union has something a bit
similar called the everything but arms
and the problem with both these schemes
is that although depth
they've already conceded the principle
that Africa needs some protection from
Asia in these markets they fail on
detail the girl fails because it's much
too short term it's granted for just a
three-year window at a time and so
what's happening at the moment in
Madagascar is the export firms are
hugely profitable they don't expand
because if they expand
and a go is not renewed they've sunk a
lot of costs and they don't to take that
risk that's right that's right
everything that arms is a different set
of problems like a lot of things with
the European Union
it's a massive immensely complicated
rules rules of origin in particular it's
very limited in scope it only covers the
least developed countries what I've been
urging and I think it's a big
opportunity for the g8 of this summer is
to combine the best of a goer and
everything but arms try and bring the
Japanese in as well have a an OECD wide
temporary protection scheme for Africa
against Asia how temporary I'd say
target 2015
that's the horizon for the Millennium
Development Goals let's say we phase out
all that protection by 2015 Africa has a
decade to get its to break into these
markets but already for instance this
removal of textile quarter is Harding
American African textile industry that's
right that's right so that Africa's
taking a big hit and it needs to have
this this offsetting temporary advantage
now all all there is to do with the
third of Africa that could realistically
break into these global markets the
countries that have a lot of natural
resource wealth realistically probably
can't because there isn't that ironic
the countries which have resources
well the the it's the explanation is
basically Dutch disease alright that
explain that please okay so what we mean
by Dutch disease is that because the
countries got a lot of foreign exchange
earnings coming from natural resources
that makes other export activities under
competitive unprofitable within the
country the country has already got the
export earnings it needs from from from
diamond diamonds or
book site whatever phosphates it's it's
not the Dutch disease is called Dutch
disease because it first happened in in
the Netherlands with North Sea gas
leading to the contraction of Dutch
manufacturing activities it's not
absolutely inevitable Indonesia managed
to combine oil with manufacturing export
expansion because it used the oil money
very intelligently to lower the costs
for manufacturing and so it's not a
complete nono but it makes life much
more difficult for these export
breakthroughs but globalisation still
really really matters with this natural
resource wealth because what's happened
in Africa to date has been that the the
pattern of extraction of resource
extraction has been very corrupting of
governance the the way the contracts
have been negotiated in the first place
has been corrupt the revenues that have
been paid had been completely non
transparent the structure of risks has
left the countries with very volatile
revenue flows and the companies
protected this cocktail has massively
undermined governance and so you get the
paradox that the counter is with the
biggest revenue influences have actually
achieved the least in basic public
service delivery this is this situation
the result of the kind of colonial rule
the type of colonial administration
existed is a continuation of that
colonial administration no I think I
think we blame too much on colonialism
it's and a lot of my African friends
would say the same that Africans got to
take responsibility for African outcomes
the group of Africans that particularly
have to take responsibility are a pretty
limited bunch of dictators for much of
the 1980s in the 1990s Africa
democratized and sadly even in the
democracies the cocktail of resource
wealth resource rents and democracy
didn't work out very well because what
tended to do was subvert the democratic
process democracy turned into a
patronage game patronage politics
instead of part is competing to deliver
services to to the mass of the
population we saw back in a couple of
episodes for example of democracy in
Nigeria
what democracy tended to mean was
electoral competition and that didn't
have very good effects now because
that's not the only thing we mean by
democracy a full democracy we also mean
checks and balances turns out
empirically statistically that in the
countries with lots of resource friends
checks and balances are really important
in getting growth and poverty reduction
the instant democracies we saw in Africa
in the 1990s were instant electoral
competition you can do you can hold an
election anywhere even in Afghanistan
right what you can't do instantly is
build these checks and balances and they
haven't been built in Africa the present
reforming government in Nigeria is
trying to put in place those checks and
balances and it's a very brave and
difficult struggle but in order to build
these checks and balances build
institutions you need a middle class and
from what I gather that middle class is
still very very tiny yeah and so what
you're saying is don't start from here
now the other thing you could be saying
is well that gives the international
community a role globalization a role
globalization can't just mean let's go
in and buy the resources from whichever
crook will sell it to his
most cheaply right globalization
responsible globalization has gotta mean
we help the weak group in Africa the the
small weak middle class as it were and
the silent poor to get these checks and
balances in place it's our
responsibility to help that there's the
starting to be an initiative the to its
credit the British government launched
this extractive industries transparency
initiative which came out of the very
good NGO movement Global Witness
published what you pay and what that's
trying to do is get some integrity into
these resource revenues so this this is
one positive aspect of globalization
that NGOs international NGOs are getting
involved in bringing some transparency
and a lot of what NGOs do fees of the
Africa is really dumb Africa needs all
the help it can get from people care
about it and more than half the time in
my view the people who care about Africa
are pushing for the wrong things in this
case one little NGO made a big impact
who's started to make it in big impact
pushing on the right thing the corporate
social responsibility agenda for the
extractive industries in Africa should
be governance governance governance most
of the time at a moment the corporate
social responsibility agenda that's
being pushed has been the wrong agenda
it's been labor standards and
environment I don't mean to say they
count for nothing but they're trivial
issues compared with getting the
governance of these massive resource
friends which are vastly bigger than the
aid flows to Africa and at the moment
had positively dysfunctional that's
where the corporate social
responsibility action needs to be but
but before you can actually enforce
corporate social responsibility first of
all you need to stop the civil war which
is perhaps affecting most of this
resource which countries
that I the Civil War Oh searches ham
it's affecting some of them the the
problem of Civil War is is really a
cocktail of risks there's no one thing
which says this is the cause right I
think of countries as being prone to
civil war if they have a few
characteristics I found in fact that the
characteristics which really matter turn
out to be economic a lot of the
attentions on the politics but it's
actually a lethal economic cocktail of
three things one is poverty just low
income second thing is economic decline
so not just the level of income but the
rate of change if you're in economic
decline the risks go up a lot I suppose
this there's no hope especially for
young people and the third risk factor
is indeed the natural resources partly
it's an attractive resource to to fight
over party it actually helps to finance
the the conflict you can get away with
any one of those but if you've got all
three of them yep you're living
dangerously you're playing Russian
roulette and maybe you can play Russian
roulette successfully for a long time
and then if the wrong chamber comes
round these civil wars typically once
they've started a very hard to stop even
when they stop there's about a 50% risk
that you go back into conflict within
the next decade so there's a what I call
a conflict trap you live dangerously
before you fall off the cliff because
you've got this lethal cocktail and then
and then you're stuck for a long time
and so these that the kind of failed
state that you have been studying this
ently
and study on the field states she could
tell us as to how do you define a failed
state yeah I think there are actually
two categories relieving one we've just
talked about is the the states that are
visibly failing because they're in civil
war another category is failing states
that are that are peace and but they're
still failing who are they failing it's
not we're failing out they're failing
their own citizens by having some
cocktail of bad policies bad
institutions bad governance which
condemns them to both low incomes and an
economic decline now those
characteristics also feed on to a risk
of war but it's a slightly different
phenomenon that the failing states at
peace now the failed States and you said
that they're failing their own citizens
but they're failing the world as well
and this is what I think perhaps it
would be useful for you to explain as to
why does it or is it matter to the US or
anybody that States in Africa failing
yeah there there are ripple effects that
spillover from state failure and you can
think of it as layers the the first
layer beyond the country itself is the
neighborhood and that's a big ripple
effect among the more of the costs of
both of Civil War and of failing states
that are stay at peace more of the costs
are inflicted on neighbors that are
infected by my ocean well it's a mixture
it's it's a neighborhood effect which
reduces economic activity so growth is
hit across the region there's a big
impact on migration and that migration
typically spreads disease and so one
massive effect is is
an increase in mortality rates for
example the spread of malaria so you've
got powerful neighborhood effects these
these costs are highly persistent even
when conflicts are over and economies
reform because health states all these
disease vectors are highly persistent so
a lot of the costs and some of my
analyses most of the costs of a civil
war the carafe Terr it's over and you
get a piece that you're still paying for
this country but we've so far only
looked at the neighborhood ripple there
are big costs that ripple not just their
neighbors they come right across the
Atlantic and they come here and let me
point to I guess three of them one is
the health costs disease doesn't know
boundaries right dizzy germs don't need
a passport
there's reasonably good evidence that
the global pandemic of AIDS came out of
an african civil war simple reason is
the in civil war you get a combination
of two phenomena which spread sexually
transmitted disease basically one is
mass rape because you've got a lot of
armed combatants and a very poor control
it's a mass rape and mass population
movement and that cocktail spreads
secretary transmitted disease so there's
a reasonable case that the World AIDS
pandemic came out of one African civil
war if we could have averted that just
think of the benefits to mankind
the second area is is drugs hard drugs
hard drugs are an enormous problem both
America and Europe the costs are
astounding because of the link between
hard drugs and criminality so drugs have
been produced in discounts something
like 95 percent of world production of
hard drugs is in civil war environments
or post-civil war environments and
there's a very simple reason for that to
produce hard drugs you need territory
outside the control of a recognized
government inadvertently or possibly
deliberately that is what is generated
by civil wars in fact you get rebel
movements which evolved to become drug
baron it's reasonable interpretation of
what's being going on in Colombia is
that some of the rebel groups have
evolved into drug baron is with a veneer
of politics so drugs disease drugs and
then the third which is the more
speculative his safe havens for
terrorism and finance for terrorism the
it's was nowhere fluke that al-qaeda
holed up in Afghanistan which was at
that time a failing state civil war
environment after all the 9/11
terrorists weren't actually Afghani they
moved to Afghanistan because it offered
them a safe haven a safe haven of
territory outside the control of a
recognized government so the there's
some evidence tracing financing for
al-qaeda to the civil wars in West
Africa diamonds and stuff so there's a
there's a security dimension to this
as well as a disease dimension and an
economic divide and then the crime that
specialist financial scams that's I
think Nigeria's can I'm almost to world
capital isn't it yes yes yes I mean the
president reform government is really
trying to clean that up
but basically both criminals terrorists
and germs want territory outside the
control of an effective state in the
modern world there aren't many of these
such havens it would be a feasible goal
to say over the next 20 years let's get
rid of all of them alright the
instrument for that doesn't have to be
military there are actually more
cost-effective ways have transforming
States than invading them so you're just
concluding thoughts are what are you
going to see in Africa in the next 10-15
years do you because you've said that in
terms of manufacturing export Africa's
case is very now very weak because IV
Asia is going to be very different I
think what we're going to see is is
differentiation I think we'll see some
African countries turning around
breaking through into the soil of high
growth rates we've seen in Asia Africa
has a lot of countries what oh let's
take
Ghana Senegal Madagascar Tanzania would
all be examples of countries with
coastal locations that could make a
credible thrust into global markets
right then I think we'll see another
group of countries turning around the
management of their natural resource
wealth they've already got a great model
which is Botswana Botswana an African
democracy which managed to build the
checks and balances which made its
resource wealth really valuable for its
population
for many years Botswana was not just the
fastest growing economy in Africa it was
the fastest growing economy on earth it
moved from dirt poverty to middle-income
status and it moved fast that's the
model that Nigerians who are now trying
to implement reform are trying to pick
up they're trying to turn Nigeria into a
big Botswana it's not easy right they're
heroes they're receiving death threats
from the rent seekers who want to stop
that because it's not going to benefit
everybody and but we've got to see some
successes like that once we've got some
successes we're going to see all sorts
of pressures the power of example the
power of protest the power of
international standards spreading those
examples across Africa well with that
positive not thank you
Paul Collier for visiting us and for
this very fascinating interview thank
you very much indeed